you know how everyone loves the right
guessing meme no here's the thing I'm
really not like down with the kids so
memeing hash tagging all that stuff is
like welcome back to glamour with me
joshing soon host and today we're joined
by Claire Foy now before we kick
anything off mm-hmm
any intergalactic adventure you need
some space snacks we've got some space
snacks for you keep those yeah not sure
if they're tasty an Ice Cream Sandwich
how does that work does anyone need an
Ice Cream Sandwich in space hey why not
tastebuds might take you there thanks
for a special occasion
you really are the beating heart of this
film and when it comes to doing a roll
with traditional people we've seen as a
wife roll they are kind of like the
hidden role models behind this whole
story and you're such a great role model
for women everywhere and men as well
yeah I think so is that something you
want to try and get out of them and get
that across and show the public how
instrumental they were to this amazing
story the more I learned about these
women I knew that although it might seem
to some people that they would just the
wife they were just at home that they
really were living their own lives and
dealing with their own things and you
could make a whole other movie about
just them when demi was making the film
he didn't want to make it this isn't a
film just about the moon landing is
about those 10 years of the space
program and and I think that he didn't
want to make a film which everyone
already seen I think everyone's already
seen the kind of critic cookie-cutter
1960s perfect family and so he was
always going to make a film about men
and women and children and how they were
all affected in this and and so I felt
like we were giving a voice to lots of
women who never give another chance at
that time and now if you were gonna be a
space tourist in your life hmm what kind
of space tourists would you be I've got
a couple of scenarios be okay go on hit
me
would you smashed a trolley bar and just
hope for the best
let's hope there's a trolley bar
situation yeah would you just get your
best sheet astronaut outfit and swagger
all over the moon
or would you jump ship before even to
carve if I was in there definitely have
some alcohol but I'd probably be
flooring my weight holding onto the
outside saying don't make me go don't
let me go because you've also said
before you kind of like lose it a bit
when you see people in Hollywood like
with Kate Winslet when it came to
meeting Ryan Gosling for the first time
did you lose it or did you keep it
together
what was the far if I'd have lost it it
would have been really embarrassing I
don't like was perfectly normal
this is what I was doing on a Thursday
I've always thought he was incredible an
amazing actor but those two people
Damien Chazelle and Ryan are incredibly
down to earth and so they make it put
there is no way that you could possibly
be weird for more than a you know 30
seconds because they make it all seem so
normal so that was the oddest part of it
though by the end oversight oh I just
made a film with these two people I'm
not really realized it because they're
just so genuine lovely down-to-earth
people because where you find of like a
Ryan Gosling means it might have been in
the mean world maybe a bit a little bit
weird but I've only ever seen one mean
it might not hold on which my friend
sent me to say you need to know what I
mean is what's wrong with you and sent
me a meme when I was like oh that's a
meme and that was it well lucky if
you've got some memes hair so you can
read up on them that the Ryan Gosling
means hey girl you know what this is
sweater is made of boyfriend material
it's like a pacer with some words on it
why don't I mean that one me me it's
like yeah well as I just showed them
everywhere and this oh hey girl things
huge hey girl hey girl